hey if you want to show your love for
the seventh at least since and support
this channel at the same time check out
our brand new online store we have
original designs like this Eskin or
praise the Sun shirt created by Pro
artist Cuusoo Marie
you can't find these designs anywhere
else so check us out at anime uproar
calm link in the description fans of the
channel can now use a special discount
code uproar 25 at checkout to receive an
instant 25 percent off
[Music]
hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and in this video
we will be looking at all the known
demons in the world of the seven deadly
sins that means every known member of
the demon clan and we will be ranking
them from weakest to strongest based on
the information that we have so far a
lot of you guys requested a video on the
demon clan and I thought a video ranking
all the different demons would be a good
idea until I realized how much work it
would be but I hope that you will find
it useful to have all the different
types of demons and all the strongest
demons ranked here in one place some of
the information will be exact because
for some of the demons we already know
what their combat class or power level
is but for characters whose exact
current combat class hasn't been
confirmed I will use evidence and logic
to determine their ultimate rank before
we get started I want to take a sec to
give a huge thank you to all of you who
have been showing so much support on our
seven deadly sins videos and asking us
to make more that really means a lot to
me and I love that you enjoy and
appreciate the content so this one goes
out to all of you thank you by the way
if you enjoy these types of videos and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell there
will be some manga spoilers in this
video relating directly to the demons
and their rankings but I will do my best
to avoid unnecessary spoilers with that
said if you don't want any spoilers you
have been warned let's start things off
with the lesser demons before getting
into the higher ranked demon swirls or
the most powerful demons the cover of
chapter 259 of the manga actually offers
us a very useful chart that gives us the
many different types of lesser demons
and their combat class the weakest of
the demon race are known as the white
demons who happen to be the smallest
members of the demon clan and they tend
to walk on two feet their combat class
ranges between 150 and 250 after that we
have the green demons who look like
muscle-bound
alien caterpillars or something their
combat class ranges between 600 and 900
next we have the ochre demon slimy dudes
with multiple tentacle shaped tongues
protruding from their mouths their
combat class ranges from 800 to 1100
after them we have the cobalt demons
also known as the blue demons they have
the appearance of huge muscular Birds
and their combat class can range from as
low as 400 to as high as 1300 after the
blue chicken squad we have the first
type of demon that we are introduced to
in the entire series the fat clown demon
more commonly known as the red demon
this demons combat class ranges between
1000 and 1300 and even though they are
among the weakest demons of the demon
clan a single red demon was able to
destroy the entire fairy Kings forest
murder Elaine and nearly killed bond as
well and of course red demon blood was
used by Hendrix sent to create the new
generation of holy Knights next up is
the orange demon sometimes referred to
as the persimmon demon persimmon who
even uses that word anyway I just called
him the creepy teddy bear demons their
combat class is between 1300 and 1600
and yes I realized that their appearance
seems to be inspired by a koala rather
than a teddy bear but personally I still
prefer creepy teddy bear demon these
guys are followed by the grey demons
also known as the ash demons the grey
demons look like they are constantly
wearing a weird Venetian son mask and
hendrickson used the blood of a great
demon in order to make himself far
stronger than any of the new generation
o Knights and this is because of course
the great demon is stronger than the red
demon the grey demons combat class
ranges between 2700 and 3200 then we
have the copper demon clearly the best
looking out of all the demons so far
they walk on two legs are extremely
large have enormous physical strength
and their combat class ranges between
three thousand eight hundred and five
thousand four hundred finally we should
also mention the giant Albion golems who
grow to the size of entire mountains and
whose combat class reaches unimpressive
5500 but it is important to mention that
these guys are technically golems or
artificial creatures created by the
demon clan rather than demon
themselves all of these lesser demon
types that I just mentioned appear to
have relatively low intelligence and are
usually used as foot soldiers in the
demon armies nevertheless there do
appear to be some other demon types and
breeds who don't fall into any of these
classifications and are considered more
rare this includes whatever this thing
is and while we don't have an exact
combat class for it it appears to be
among the stronger lesser demons now of
course after all the different types of
lesser demons we have the higher demons
who are both more intelligent and more
powerful this includes the 10
commandments the elite demon clan
warriors but also other members of the
demon race who are not as strong as the
commandments but still can't be
classified as lesser demons for example
we have para Nia a small childlike demon
who is essentially a servant of more
powerful demons like zelgius she is
clearly intelligent and has interesting
demonic powers like the ability to trap
her opponents in an illusion but her
strength cannot compare to the
commandments and she is ultimately
defeated by King Arthur and his pet calf
we also have demons like dairy Ares
sister we don't know exactly how strong
she was but we know that she along with
many other members of the demon clan
were being held hostage by the goddess
clan during the previous holy war the
commandments tried to rescue the
hostages including derriere sister but
ultimately all the hostages were killed
by the goddess clan we can assume that
since they were kidnapped and the
commandments were sent to rescue them
dari Ares sister and the other hostages
were not necessarily as strong as the
elite warriors known as the commandments
although obviously all of these less
powerful demons who were taken hostage
would all be far stronger than any
ordinary human we also have demons like
Clarissa the woman that the demon goal
third the creator of the doll go through
was in love with at some point three
thousand years earlier she was killed by
the strongest of the four Archangels
Miele and the demon goat her was so
devastated by her death that he designed
the doll go third to look a lot like her
again this is a case where we don't
exactly know how strong she was all we
know is that she was killed by my al but
since the commandments our Allah
demon warriors and larysa was not one of
them we can reasonably assume that she
was not as strong as then and this
brings us to the commandments themselves
the Ten Commandments are elite warriors
selected by the demon king as a demon
special forces unit of sorts however
historically not all members of the ten
commandments were born into the demon
clan some were originally members of
other races including drôle gloxinia and
the dal go there who doesn't have a race
because he is a doll
I will not include them because they are
not real demons the Ten Commandments
were created when the demon king who is
the ruler of the entire demon clan
separated half of his own power into ten
pieces and gave each piece to one of the
ten warriors who would make up the Ten
Commandments as a result each warrior
has a unique commandment a special power
that can put a curse on whoever breaks
the specific rule or commandment that
this warrior possesses former members of
the ten commandments who had already
stopped being members when the
commandments are first introduced in the
story include commodious who was
defeated by drawling gloxinia with some
help from le otis our anak and Zeno who
were apparently killed by Mel Yoda's
after he decided to betray the
commandments and of course Mele Otis
himself as well as the demon Gotha and a
doll Golder we will talk about my Leodis
and go through a little bit later but at
this point we can't be exactly sure how
strong calm adios our anak and Zeno were
back when they were commandments we can
assume that they were at the same level
as at least some of the current
commandments so they were elite demon
fighters who are among the strongest of
the demon clan now let's talk about the
members of the ten commandments as they
are when we first meet them in the
series in the past I made an entire
video describing all of the members of
the ten commandments and their powers in
great detail so I will link that video
in the description and a good friend of
mine Briggs from all de anime made a
video ranking the current Ten
Commandments in particular I will also
link that video below if you want to
check it out Briggs does a good job of
not only looking at the known power
levels but also considering the impact
of the various special abilities and
specific commandments for each member
but to be brief at number 10 we have
fraud Rijn who was not an original
command
mint but rather a replacement for an
original members so he is not considered
to be as strong as the others at number
9 we have Galland who is very strong but
also shows himself to be very reckless
and that ends up being his undoing and
at number eight we have grey road whose
ability to summon demons and the
commandment of pacifism are both very
impressive next at number seven is Mel
ask Allah who doesn't have the highest
power level but has some insane
abilities including bringing back the
dead
stealing Souls and using the very
powerful cocoon of darkness at number 6
his drawl who is a giant and not a demon
but he was for a time a member of the 10
commandments and the number five is
gloxinia who is actually a fairy not a
demon but was also a member of the 10
commandments for a time at number 4 is
the undisputed hottest girl in the
entire series derriere II whose special
ability combo star gets stronger the
more consecutive blows she is able to
land until it becomes so strong that it
can even threaten someone as powerful as
meliodas and at number three is maan
speed who has an extremely high power
level and insane special abilities like
trick star it is important to note that
both dari areum and speed are also able
to use the in do de transformation which
makes them even stronger and speaking of
in Duda we also know that another demon
exists by the name of Baraka or Bharucha
anyway it's ba ru J a who was an
acquaintance of Galland and underwent
the indirect transformation at some
point he is believed to still be
wandering about somewhere possibly
inside the demon realm and the fact that
he was able to undergo the indirect
transformation means that his power
level was a minimum of 50,000 before the
transformation making him also one of
the strongest members of the demon clan
and finally the two strongest members of
the Ten Commandments are zelgius and
esta rosa i will talk about zelgius a
little bit later and i will have to put
an asterisk beside as to Rose's name I
won't tell you why in case you haven't
read the manga yet but it's not because
he's on steroids and if you have read
the manga then you know exactly what I
mean before we get into the absolutely
strongest members of the demon clan we
have to briefly talk about the six
nights of black these six powerful
demons are the main antagonists in the
new seven
Sion's movie prisoners of the sky which
came out in august of 2018 even though
they only appear in the movie they are
still sort of Canon because they are
mentioned by name in Chapter 203 of the
seven deadly sins manga and they were
created by the manga cannabic a Tsuzuki
himself we have to mention this group of
six demons because their strength was
directly compared to the strength of the
Ten Commandments in the manga so they
are considered to be at that elite demon
warrior level as well the six members of
the Knights of Bloch include the leader
blue bond sad Eskin or half man half
lava face scrotum chin x marks the waifu
and of course my boy pomp no matter how
hard I looked I could not find the
prisoners of the sky movie anywhere
outside of Japan so I can't speak too
much about the specifics in terms of
which of the six nights is stronger than
the other or how they compare to the
different members of the ten
commandments what we do know is that
they have been compared to the
commandments in terms of strength that
blue bond is the leaders so presumably
the strongest and that all six members
of the knights of black appeared to have
red demon marks instead of black marks
whatever that means if you actually
manage to watch the movie maybe you'll
live in Japan or something feel free to
let me know what you thought of the six
nights of black and how strong they are
down in the comments and now we get into
the highest-ranked demons in the demon
clan starting things off with Cusack an
extremely powerful demon who is the
former master of zeldron essentially he
was the one who trained Zell drous
despite being an older demon ku sucks
highest recorded power level in his true
form is a whopping one hundred and sixty
eight thousand his power is set to rival
the power of zelgius himself and he is
considered stronger than multiple
members of the ten commandments put
together on top of having an impressive
power level Cusack also has the special
ability called resonant which allows him
to possess an opponent through eye
contact and make that person make the
same movements that Cusack himself is
making allowing him to essentially force
a person to kill themselves if he so
chooses next up is Chandler
sorry I couldn't help myself
the demon Chandler is like you suck one
of the highest-ranking and oldest
members of the demon clan just like who
suck was the master of zeldron Chandler
was the master of mealy Otis and he was
the one who taught meliodas many of his
best known abilities including full
counter
Chandler's highest measured power level
thus far is 173,000 even higher than
kusa and Chandler also possesses some
incredible special abilities including
true Knight which turns everything
around him into complete darkness even
in the middle of the day and using this
ability he was even able to force s
kannur to turn back into his knight form
in the middle of the day like Cusack
Chandler is also believed to be stronger
than multiple Commandments put together
and zelgius believes that Chandler could
defeat all of the seven deadly sins
except for meliodas on his own then we
come to Zell drous earlier on in the
story I would not have placed Zell drous
this high definitely not ahead of Kusaka
and Chandler but recent events in the
manga have demonstrated that Zell drous
is indeed that strong as we know Zell
drous is the youngest son of the demon
king and he is acting as the demon Kings
representative celtris innate power is
the power granted to him directly by the
demon king also referred to as the power
of god celtris is committed to becoming
the next demon king himself and he also
has the ability known as desiree which
lets him create a portal to a specific
target and strike the target down with a
lightning bolt even though his highest
measured power level so far has only
been just over 60,000 in reality zelgius
is far stronger than that
due to the power that he borrowed
directly from the demon king himself
even Kusaka and Chandler are intimidated
by the current strength of zeldron his
special ability called ominous nebula
allows him to generate an overpowered
vortex that sucks all living things
towards him and then instantly cut them
to pieces in more recent chapters
zelgius has been able to use this
ability to take on Eskin or Merlin and
the Archangel Ludo shell at the same
time and also Hendrickson and Gil
Thunder but I mean who even notices
those guys at this point and Ludo shell
even admits that zelgius is ominous Ned
is faster than his own divine grace
after Zell drous we have the original
goal thir also known as the demon gopher
to be honest I debated quite a bit as to
whether I should please go through this
high in the rankings especially since we
haven't seen very much of him in the
actual story however from what we do
know about him it is simply impossible
to ignore his immense power which has
had a massive impact on the entire world
of the seven deadly sins when he was
still alive go through was known as an
incredibly powerful wizard so much so
that the demon king forced him to become
one of the ten commandments even though
he didn't want to this means that the
demon king valued Golders abilities so
much that he simply refused to let him
go
the original goal there was also the
teacher and master of Merlin the current
greatest wizard in all of Britannia and
his magic is so sophisticated that he
was able to create the doll go through
and still make him one of the most
powerful warriors in the world even
though he was completely artificial like
the doll go their original goal had the
special ability called invasion which
allowed him to read and manipulate the
thoughts and memories of other creatures
in fact the original Gothas magic was so
strong that he was able to end the
previous holy war by manipulating the
memories of a vast number of individuals
on both sides of the conflict including
the demon king himself I won't tell you
exactly how Gotha did this in case you
haven't read the manga yet and you don't
want to be spoiled but if we take into
account the insane power of invasion and
the fact that the original goal term
managed to manipulate the demon king
himself we simply have to place him this
high on the list
don't get me wrong it's totally possible
that in a direct one-on-one battle the
original goal toward not be quite as
strong as eldress or Chandler but
keeping in mind the power of invasion
the fact that it can affect so many
people at the same time and its
long-range capabilities I think that the
original goal at his peak belongs right
here on this list however if you
disagreed that's totally cool feel free
to give me your reasoning down in the
comments and next up is of course Mele
Otis as the oldest son of the demon king
and the former leader of the ten
commandments Mele Otis has unbelievably
strong demonic powers we know that his
hell blaze is so powerful that it can
even injure immortal creatures like bond
and stop them from regenerating and he
has some extremely useful abilities like
full counter which enable him to counter
a magical attack and reflected back at
his opponent with even greater power
than the original attack Mele Otis also
has a sacred treasure known as the demon
sword lost vein and it enables Milly
Otis to create clones of himself for
much of the series we don't know the
true extent of melioidosis power because
the majority of his power was sealed
away by Merlin in order to keep him from
losing control and going berserk but as
the story goes on we begin to understand
the staggering extent of melioidosis
power including the fact that he was
cursed by the demon king so that he
cannot die meaning that meliodas is
essentially immortal after unlocking his
demonic powers and while in his assault
mode meliodas power level has been
measured to be as high as 140 mm but
that is before meliodas begins absorbing
the demon Kings Commandments in an
attempt to challenge the demon king
himself take his place as the ruler of
all the demons and remove the curse that
the demon king placed on him at this
point in the manga the power of meliodas
has risen exponentially and he was shown
to be able to take on Zell drous as the
Rossa and Cusack at the same time not
only that but in purgatory meliodas his
emotions so only one part of meliodas
are able to give the demon king a run
for his money with the help of bond and
wild we can safely assume that after he
absorbs the commandments and or after he
is reunited with his emotions and
becomes whole again
Mele Otis could easily become the single
most powerful demon in the entire series
however for the time being Mele Otis
remains second to the demon king the
demon king is the strongest out of all
the demons and he is believed to be
immortal as he appears to have already
lived for aeons it is said that the
demon king created the ten commandments
by dividing his own power in half and
granting 1/10 of that half to each of
the commandments this means that if you
put all 10 commandments together they
will all measure up to only half of the
demon Kings full potential and that is
assuming that the demon king hasn't
gotten even stronger since first
creating the commandments the demon king
is able to live inside purgatory
a place where ordinary creatures cannot
even survive and he appears to be able
to control the entire purgatory realm he
possesses some of the most overpowered
abilities in the entire series such as
the ruler a magical ability that enables
him to reverse all attacks used against
him so that instead of hurting him they
actually heal and strengthen him he can
also manipulate the elements grant
powers to others as in the case of the
commandments and place nearly
unbreakable curses on people as in the
case of melioidosis curse the demon
Kings exact power level has not been
mentioned yet although based on the
power of the individual Commandments we
can speculate that the demon Kings full
potential may be well over 500 thousand
that is well over half a million however
this is just speculation as a right now
and it has not been confirmed and that
is it the entire demon clan and all the
known demons ranked from weakest to
strongest please let me know if you
agree with my rankings down in the
comments and of course let me know if I
missed any of the demons from the manga
keep in mind that I did not count the
vampires as demons since they are
technically their own race even though
they were allied with the demons if you
enjoyed these types of videos and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell be sure to
check us out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest updates
and don't forget to check out our online
store where you can get original designs
by Cuusoo Murray that you won't find
anywhere else it's a great way to
support the channel and also get cool
anime merch at the same time that you
can show off or maybe give as a gift if
you made it all the way through this
video and if you did by the way I
commend you
you can type hashtag sad askin or in the
comments to let me know as always thank
you so much for watching it means a lot
and until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you